[Musique]
et une palme d'or décernée à l'unanimité
dixit le jury à parasites de bong joon
ho cette palme d'or étaient à la fois
attendue parce que parasite s'étaient
installés dès sa projection en tête des
classements des critiques internationaux
mais c'est tout donne un événement bon
je n'avais été sélectionné qu'une fois
en compétition avec oak ja en 2017 et il
n'avait jamais reçu le moindre prix
c'est pourtant lui qui va offrir sa
première palme d'or à la corée du sud un
pays qui a vu éclore une pléthore de
grands metteurs en scène depuis une
vingtaine d'années fallait avoir du
flair pour deviner que cette compétition
très relevée entre almodovar les
dardenne malik tarantino ken loach aller
sacré la outsiders bong joon ho et il se
trouve que frédéric mercier l'avait
annoncé alors on l'applaudît parasites
commence comme une comédie sur la
cohabitation d'une famille riche et
d'une famille pauvre dans une maison
luxueuse de l'alliance de l'humour et du
thriller parce que ça tourne vite
vinaigre quand même et l'une des marques
de fabrique de bong joon ho c'est ça que
vous aviez vu frédéric entre autres
ouvriers pas seulement seul film est
tellement riche il ya tellement de
choses dans ce film est tellement
d'aspérités dans ce film qu'on pourrait
pas le réduire simplement je dirais aux
côtés de thriller thriller social et le
côté comique mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
toujours eu de l'humour dans le cinéma
de bong genou il ya toujours eu la
combat social qui était menée par les
personnages on n'a qu'à penser à son
premier film memories of murder qui
était déjà un film où les
interrogatoires étaient extrêmement
drôle malgré la violence même de ces
interrogatoires et quand on pense par
exemple à zéro ce qui est sans doute son
plus grand succès son film le plus
célèbre
il y avait déjà cette solidarité
incroyable dans la famille face à je
dirais le danger du monde et le danger
du monde social de ce qui s'abattait sur
eux et évidemment il y à tout ça dans ce
film avec l'humour et particuliers donc
jeanne où je dirais que c'est un humour
qui va toujours vers la bouffonnerie
on est presque dans deux heures de
burlesque d articuler les personnages en
font un peu trop et ça permet d'éviter
toujours le pathos alors que ce qu'il
raconte est toujours plus beau montrer
de quelque chose dont un ou des images
moi je vais vous montrer le début du
film je vais vous montrer le début du
film dans la maison dont vous voyez
il ya le monde via le réel derrière
cette fenêtre et évidemment ils en sont
comme éloignés et là vous voyez il ya ce
mouvement de la caméra
cette caméra elle descend elle descend
sous la rue où il y avait même les
poubelles on va sous terre on va sous
terre ça veut dire qu'on va dans cette
maison où ces gens vivent sous terre
kabyle vivre en enfer ils vivent sous
terre il vivent dans cet endroit et
voyez que le lien avec le réel
le seul lien qui est encore possible
avec le réel c'est un lien qui passe par
la connexion avec l'internet soutenu et
donc l'enjeu de cette ouverture de film
est quand même incroyable ça va être de
trouver du réseau et en lavant vous avez
la maestria de baume genou ça veut dire
ce plan séquence qui permet de présenter
extrêmement bien les personnages mais de
présenter aussi l'exiguïté de cette
maison où tous ces gens vivent les uns
avec les autres et ça vous rappelle
l'année dernière ça vous rappelle il
affaire de famille de corée où
exactement de la même manière on était
aussi dans une maison exigu et il
fallait que tous les personnages
puissent trouver leur place pour pouvoir
essayer de cohabiter et de vivre dans
cet élan de solidarité qui unit les
membres de cette famille qui voit là on
reconnaît le grand comédien de muggiano
son compte par ces photos on découvre
aussi que la mer était championne
athlétique et donc voyez la chasse aux
réseaux la chasse à l'extérieur la
chasse avec un avec un réseau c'est à
dire avec une connu mais une
communication une connexion avec le
monde pour ces gens est encore là et là
vous voyez évidemment l'insecte qui vit
sous terre comme ce parasite qui est
déjà dans la maison et là vous avez le
côté burlesque du cinéma de beaune jeune
homme est un burlesque qui révèle aussi
tout le caractère dramatique de cette
situation puisque ces gens sont obligés
de se mettre près des toilettes
accroupis pour pouvoir avoir une
dernière connexion avec le monde et
trouver tout simplement un emploi
le film de genre le film politique ce
dont parle frédéric en fait la fonction
du cinéma de boulot ici fille
oui alors ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que en recueillant sa palme il a
voulu mettre son film sous l'égide de
claude chabrol et d'henri georges
clouzot et je pense que ce sont deux
cinéastes clés pour comprendre
l'entreprise parasite est intarissable
sur le salaire de la peur
et ben oui parce que il a trouvé chez
ces cinéastes
une manière de
parler de la société de faire des films
politiques mais déguisé dans des films
j'allais pas dire deux jambes des films
très narratif qui raconte des histoires
frédéric l'a très bien montré dès le
début on est captivé par cette histoire
et regardez la mise en scène c'est à
dire que le premier plan que tu nous
montres c'est un cadre dans le cadre
c'est-à-dire qu'on voit quand même la
société à travers un filtre et puis la
caméra descend c'est à dire qu'il ya ce
qu'on cadres et ya ce qu'il ya en
dessous ou à côté
sept espèces de parasites et qui est le
parasite évidemment on dit qu'au début
mais plus on avance dans le film plus
chacun et le parasite de l'autre il y
mettrez mais je trouve intéressant qui
parlera évidemment lui l'appareil de
chabrol dans les georges clouzot et tout
ce qu'on fait c'est un cinéaste très
méchant qui parle très bien de la
méchanceté du monde mais en fait
méchanceté plus méchanceté ça donne
aussi des grands moments de tendresse
c'est à dire c'est ça qui est absolument
fou c'est que gad gaïa de la douceur
dans cette histoire de cafard cafards
dans tous les sens du terme ça pourrait
nous donner le cafard et en même temps
il ya un truc espèce de rage sociale
derrière le burlesque est derrière ces
cessions devraient ce qui donne envie de
se battre de sortir deux de ses
bas-fonds en fait mais c'est son film le
plus révoltés enfin pour moi c'est celle
house et sarah sa colère est la plus
évidente effectivement ils s'amusent sur
le thème de parasites et s'amuse avec
nous notre attente on s'attend à de la
science fiction
en fait ils saluent cela c'est la
réalité qui est une la science fiction
et qui est le parasite est ce que ce
sont ces hommes qui remonte des égouts
cesser ce sont les jeux sur iphone et
vous verrez le plus sûr - dans la
compétition ou constamment qu'on voit le
film ya des rebondissements sa vie peut
rien dire
pour il faut le dire quoi et
l'impression d'en raconter que c'est un
thriller à chausse-trappes qu'il ya
constamment des rebondissements qui
relie la syrie la libye à un moment dans
le film tous les liquides entier se met
à hurler il ya un twist est tout à coup
être mâchoires se décroche et c'est un
film en le voyant vous savez vous irez
le voir parce qu'il ya tellement de
couches effectivement et ça raconte
tellement de choses complètement
complètement folle mais salle raconte
avec des images qui vous imprimez la
rétine vraiment parce que ce logement
extraordinaire que tu viens montrer où
les toilettes sont sous le plafond sur
une espèce de trône enfin on est on est
dans un monde irréel et en même temps un
moment il va être par exemple comment
dire noyer d'ailleurs une inondation et
l'inondation dans un sous sol
ça produit quelque chose vraiment de
l'ordre de la delà de la survie enfin
voilà on est vraiment dans l'année donc
vous vous baladez entre le rire la
terreur et la vraie émotion c'est un
film avec lequel on finit un peu triste
on sait que bon je dois fait des études
de sociologie il faut il faut redire
quelque chose c'est quelqu'un qui est un
observateur social incroyable et il le
remet dans son film son film est d'une
précision sur la manière dont il dépend
ses personnages
vous allez découvrir la palme d'or très
vite puisque parasites de bons que je ne
sera dans les salles françaises dès le 5
juin évidemment il faut pas le rater
sous aucun prétexte